ah
bienvenidos de meses maría como esta
mire yo recuerdo cuando tenía
aproximadamente como 5 o 6 años íbamos a
pasar navidad a la casa de la abuela y
me llamaba la atención que cuando
llegaba a donde estaba la sala
encontraba un árbol genealógico donde
estaban primeramente las fotos de mis
abuelos y luego pues como no había mucha
tecnología en ese tiempo pues un montón
de chamacos verdad estaban mi papá mi
mamá mis tíos con sus respectivas
esposas sus respectivas esposas y cada
quien hacía un miembro de la familia lo
iban integrando en esa en ese árbol
genealógico ahora me di cuenta de algo
durante las prácticas navideñas aunque
yo tenía muchos meses cuando mi abuelo
falleció
se contaba lo que había hecho mi abuelo
y de alguna manera u otra había afectado
a la generación presente
entonces esto me lleva a una conclusión
lo que hicieron los que nos antecedieron
nos han afectado de alguna manera u otra
y lo que nosotros vamos a hacer las
decisiones que tomemos de ahora en
adelante van a afectar a las futuras
generaciones y vamos a hablar hoy de lo
que es legal la diferencia de una
herencia una herencia tú la recibes a
base de bienes materiales casas autos y
otros bienes pero una herencia también
conlleva lo que es valores y ética
toda esa formación que nosotros vamos a
dejar nos lleva a una pregunta
que el legado vamos a dejar en las
siguientes generaciones las decisiones
que hoy tomemos lo que hoy decidamos lo
que hagamos hoy van a afectar de una
manera positiva o de una manera negativa
a las siguientes generaciones
y para saber cómo vamos a forjar un
legado que realmente traiga un beneficio
a la sociedad
se los quiero representar a través de lo
que es un sistema de raíces hablamos del
árbol y no puede haber un árbol si no lo
conforman un sistema de raíces entonces
recuerdo que en la primaria una maestra
hizo un experimento y llevó dos
refractarios y ella había arrojado en
estos refractarios que eran
prácticamente iguales semillas de
jitomate y la única diferencia entre un
refractario y otro era la cantidad de
tierra que había el que tenía menor
cantidad de tierra a los pocos días
comienza a crecer la planta pero cuando
llegó a medir entre 15 o 20 centímetros
no pudo soportar más el crecimiento
porque no tenía un sistema de raíces
sólido y fuerte
sistema de raíces es más importante lo
que está por debajo de la tierra que lo
que vemos por encima de ella un
arquitecto sabe que de acuerdo a los
cimientos un edificio se va a poder
levantar tantos pisos arriba tan sólido
sean sus cimientos
ahora para forjar un sistema de raíces
sólido en nuestras siguientes
generaciones lo voy a explicar en dos
facetas muy muy sencillas por un lado
tenemos el poder de las palabras las
palabras son como semillas y las
semillas van a germinar de acuerdo a la
naturaleza de la misma palabras son
poderosas y lo que nosotros estamos
transmitiendo a nuestros hijos esas
palabras los van a empoderar para que
forjen realmente una identidad firme y
sólida y que puedan verse como
benefactores de la sociedad con palabras
tú puedes edificar o puedes destruir con
palabras tú puedes impulsar o puedes
frenar palabras pueden ser la razón de
tus éxitos o el motivo de tu
fracasos cuando tú le dices a tus hijos
adelante hijo vamos tú puedes sacar lo
mejor de ti no importa que te tropieces
un tropiezo no redefine quién eres tú
todas esas palabras están forjando un
sistema de raíces muy sólido
que van a traer un beneficio a todas las
personas que nos rodean y por otro lado
tenemos el poder de los modelos quien
recuerda esa película de 1984 de 'karate
kid' recuerdan
en esta película está rafael rap mayor
que interpreta el personaje de daniela
ruso este chico se cambia de ciudad y
cuando llega a la secundaria viene por
una golpiza 3 vengas entonces el chico
compra un método para aprender karate de
manera teórica y ahí lo tienen
practicando
y en otra de las discusiones que tuvo
con estos chicos le ponen otra tranquila
que si no fuera por la intervención
milagrosa verdad como se llama mister
villar y el míster villar y lo hubieran
mandado al hospital entonces él le pide
a míster villa que si lo puede entrenar
en carácter
y cuando él accede le dice lo siguiente
yo prometo enseñarte kárate pero tú
promete obedecer sin cuestionar nada yo
prometo enseñar karate y tú promete
obedecer entonces el primer día
no lo puede alabar alta recuerda pulir
encerar pulir en cerrar el chico dice
bueno primer día la paz yo vengo a
aprender karate
quién sabe dónde movido este señor
segundo día me lo ponen a lijar y fijar
pisos tercer día a pintar la barba
se imagina lo que pasaba por la mente de
este chico
él había hecho un trato para aprender
kárate
y no estaba consciente que lo estaba
aprendiendo el último día mister villar
y se le ocurrió ir a pescar y le deja
una nota donde le dice vas a pintar la
casa y llega la noche
cuando ve que todavía no termina de
pintar la habíamos terminado
se enoja el chico dice usted prometió
enseñarme karate y todos estos días no
he sido más que su maldito esclavo
y se quiere ir a el círculo daniel
conesa y ya viene verdad le dice
enséñame a pulir y le comienza a lanzar
golpes y el chico comienza a desviar los
golpes enséñame a lijar pisos cuando le
comienza a lanzar patadas del chico sí
sí está bien así
para decir el traumado con la película
no es que mi esposa me pone a cerrar
pisos
y cuando le dan una serie de golpes
el chico se da cuenta de que había
aprendido carácter sin que
conscientemente hubiera estado
consciente de que lo estaba aprendiendo
entonces modelos son más poderosos
e información por sí sola informa
ciencia y por sí sola es débil cuántos
son papás aquí levante la mano pregunta
nuestros hijos hacen lo que les decimos
que hagan o lo que nos van a hacer
lo que nos ven hacer porque es diseño
nosotros aprendemos por modelos entonces
por un lado tenemos el poder de las
palabras nosotros empoderarnos a través
de las palabras y por otro lado tenemos
el poder de los modelos si estamos
hablando del legado es cómo vamos a
forjar
identidades firmes y fuertes con una
conciencia que nuestros hijos y las
personas que nos van a seguir que sepan
que hay potencial en ellos y esto lo
aprendí de la real academia de
spider-man todo gran poder conlleva una
gran responsabilidad en cada uno de los
seres humanos hay potencial estamos
llenos de dones talentos habilidades
pero esos dones y talentos van más allá
de nosotros mismos que no solamente
veamos por nuestro propio beneficio sino
por los demás que nos veamos como
benefactores de todos los que nos rodean
y que cada cosa que hagamos la hagamos
con excelencia la excelencia no
significa no tener errores no hablamos
de perfección
hablamos de una mejora continua y que
transición hemos de una mentalidad de
amateur a una mentalidad de profesional
como si tú puedes ver en los campos de
fútbol los fines de semana sábados y
domingos que la gente va a jugar
ahora cómo distinguir un amateurs de un
profesional
cuando se quitan esos fans y ves esas
piernas
vacas flacas pálidas te das cuenta que
esa persona no es un profesional es un
amateur porque un profesional conlleva
disciplina
el amateur juega cuando le da la gana
entonces ve por su propio beneficio pero
cuando nosotros estamos forjando en
nuestras siguientes generaciones una
mentalidad abundante esto es que rompa
con estrechez que sepan nuestros hijos y
nuestros jóvenes que su vida tiene
propósito que todo comportamiento es
resultado de identidad y que los
pensamientos que abracen de sí mismo van
a forjar un carácter firme con
responsabilidad que se vean más allá de
sí mismos para que traigan beneficios en
todo lo que están creando y todo lo que
están forjando y que rompamos con esos
esquemas egoístas esto yo le llamo
vomitar los celos
como así nada que nosotros estamos
viendo por nosotros mismos lo que me
conviene lo que para mí es mejor no es
más que eso
nosotros vomitamos los egos cuando vemos
que las decisiones que tomemos aunque
sean más cómodas para mí no
necesariamente es más cómoda para los
demás
qué quiere decir pensemos en un
empresario que por años ha logrado una
fortuna con tantos años de esfuerzo con
la labor que ha realizado y él decide
cerrar su empresa y dice bueno pues ya
tengo para vivir bien toda mi vida qué
pasaría si cierra la empresa esa
decisión puede ser mucho mejor para él
pero lo que es mucho mejor para mí no
necesariamente es mucho mejor para los
demás si estamos hablando de legados hay
cosas que vamos a tener que renunciar
por las siguientes generaciones y que
podamos visualizar 50 años 100 años más
adelante yo sí puedo ver que mis nietos
van a estar platicando entre ellos y van
a decir mira lo que hizo papá león
por lo que él hizo por las decisiones
que él tomó aquí estamos y nuestra
sociedad ha sido transformada por un
sistema de raíces sólido y fuerte a
través del empoderamiento de las
palabras y a través del poder de los
modelos recuerdo que tenía como 20 o 21
años y un amigo fumaba
y su hermanito de 13 años
le puso una re prendida
terrible no porque me habías que yo
estoy fumando tú debes de fumar que le
dije
tu hermano va a ser lo que a ti te va a
hacer no lo que tú le digas que haga
hay una corresponsabilidad
este llamado es una transformación en
nuestra manera de pensar salir del
egoísmo
sabes que te protege del egoísmo
la gratitud
el poder de la gratitud
cuando tú caminas con un corazón humilde
con sencillez de corazón te vas a dar
cuenta que hay personas a tu alrededor
que te han tendido la mano
que te han ayudado que te han impulsado
que tiene abierto puertas
y solamente con un corazón humilde
puedes tener una actitud hacia la vida
donde estás contento cuando el egoísmo
solo es mal estás enojado contigo mismo
tienes cara de limón chupado
agrio
todo lo ves mal pero con un corazón
agradecido realmente
tienes una actitud muy diferente de la
piel
y la gratitud de protege de lewis
entonces volvamos al principio estamos
hablando
regeneración es un árbol genealógico
que lo conforman un sistema de raíces en
este sistema de raíces
se forja con el empoderamiento que
tenemos a través de las palabras
y el poder de los modelos
ahora
cuando tú tocas una vida
todo el adn de lo que tú estás tocando
transforma la manera de pensar
y ese sistema de raíces va a estar tan
firme tan fuerte y tan sólido para poder
soportar el crecimiento cuando viene el
crecimiento se comienzan a dar los
frutos y en cada fruto no encontramos
una sino muchas semillas que están
listas para reproducirse de una manera
exponencial
sistema de raíces es importante a través
de lo que nosotros estemos forjando
entonces cuando tú tocas una vida
estás tocando generaciones
cuando transformas una vida
transformas generaciones muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]